good morning John two weeks ago I woke
up in LA with a goal of packing in as
much internet creator hangout time as
possible
here is my journal of what I've done so
far with all of the sleeping and driving
time taken out it all began when a
certain German DJ came to my Airbnb then
we went to see our friends Greg and Kim
had dinner with Jon Cozart went on a
walk around Santa Monica shot not too
deep with the grace Helbig had Meghan
Camarena and Lee Newton over for dinner
once a year but the day with rhett and
Link and shot a good mythical morning
then went out to the launch party for
dish and after it's like yep but four
individual dishes at restaurants that
Ingrid grace mamrie and Hannah have been
working on shot some stuff at SourceFed
then you came to down we had dinner hey
John what are you talking about soccer
shot - just between us --is with Gabby
and Alison got a parking ticket so
confusing hung out with Derek from
veritasium then went to Meghan tonjes
house to hang out with cool people and
watch creepy YouTube videos chilled a
bit with Tyler I got a big question for
you explain the cloud then what did that
they may be Giants concert where I ran
into Steve Zaragoza from SourceFed had
breakfast with friends that's been a
full day at a collab camp which is a
totally new idea to me but where I met a
ton of youtubers and then had dinner
with Jake and Michael a Vsauce spent a
full day at BuzzFeed where I made a
bunch of stuff and talked to him to cool
people but only filmed this one clip
shot I think Google's working on had
lunch with Mayim Bialik then went to
three black dot to talk shop and play
with the HTC vive then had dinner with
Matt Pat of the game theorists went
shopping with heartbeat and foxy at the
Grove had a quick chat with markiplier
followed by dinner with Hannah Hart her
sister Maggie and Mitchell Davis and I
still have so much more to do shooting
youtubers reacts recording with a
Gilmore guys and Travis McElroy more fun
more friends John I am a fan I'm a
careful fan but once I am a fan I'm an
unabashed fan there's an element in my
appreciation of other people's work
that's more of like I want to be like
them I want to make things as good as
what they make and I think that's where
some of my ambition comes from but I
also just simply enjoy liking them and
the things they make I like liking that
stuff sometimes I like you gets caught
up with I want to be like you but those
things are not the same thing and
realizing that has been a really big
deal for me I really enjoyed this trip
but I do not want to live in LA because
I do not want this fortnight to be
normal
I need to be a step away being an
observational fan is in a lot of ways
better than being inside I never want to
lose the fan bit
otherwise these last weeks would not
have been as invigorating or inspiring
as they have I am a fan of the things
these people create I am a fan of the
fact that the Internet has allowed them
to do it I'm just so pleased and feel so
lucky I get to be friends with the
people I'm fans of and in one case I get
to be brothers with them too which maybe
makes me the luckiest fan ever John I'll
see you on Tuesday